Hello! Welcome to Michael's Better Business English.
This month, we're looking at a difficult but important topic in business:...
...How to apologize politely.
Now, this is a very difficult area for many Japanese business people...
...because it's very different culture to culture.
Traditional Japanese polite style, meaning uses lots of polite language and bowing...
...but it's quite different than say, Western style.
In countries such as America or Germany, apologizing is usually used rarely...
...and to indicate accepting personal responsibility.
So, you need to be careful when and how should you apologize...
...when working with people from different cultures.
Some advice to help you in general though, when apologizing to Western business people.
Use these four steps.
First, apologize.
For example, "We are so sorry for the delay of the delivery."
Second, give a clear reason for the problem.
"This was due to a mistake in our factory."
Third, make an action clear that you will take in order to avoid the problem from happening again.
Example, "We are changing our factory production schedule to avoid any future delays."
And then finally, apologize again.
"Again, we'd like to apologize for this accident."
Use these four steps for a polite, clear, and effective apology.
Thank you and good luck!